my name is Edward Norton I founded
Crowdrise with three partners it's an
internet platform that is engineered
specifically to facilitate and maximize
individual fundraising efforts whether
in the context of an individual wanting
to support a cause that they care about
or for an organization building a
platform through which they reach down
through their support base and engineer
grassroots crowd-sourced fundraising we
felt that there was a gap between the
experience that people have when they
network for social purposes and the
substance of being engaged in a good
cause in a nutshell to us Crowdrise was
like let's try to fuse these two things
let's try to let's try to pull some of
the substance from one side of the
equation in with the fun of the other
side and make something that's really
altogether new which is a different way
of expressing your identity